ok let's get into audience questions for
the week and they are good and they are
very meaty this week the first is hey
David
when will the Constitution be officially
outdated this is so loaded and it just
to begin with there are lots of people
who just say never they're called
constitutional fetishists sometimes they
call into the show but if we want to
have a sensible adult conversation the
first question is what do you mean by
outdated if you mean does the
Constitution still effectively establish
the federal government and give us the
original set of powers for the federal
government it still does that and in
that sense it's not outdated in that it
still outlines the government that we
have today if the question which I think
is a more practical question becomes
does the Constitution still serve as a
relevant document to answer questions
about how things should work today the
answer is that with every passing year
the Constitution increasingly fails to
be a document that gives us those
answers so in many ways the Constitution
is already outdated look at the chaos
around gun laws is it the guns that were
around at the time of the Constitution's
rioting or do we need to interpret which
guns and types of arms fall under the
jurisdiction of what the founders meant
when the Second Amendment was
established what what exist its
immediate and total chaos the problem is
either it's outdated or it isn't and the
chaos starts when we start arguing about
which pieces are outdated and in which
way and we start trying to suss out the
intentions of the founders versus
whether a totally literal interpretation
should be applied but if it is a little
literal interpretation it should be
applied based on the world that existed
at the time that the Constitution or its
amendments were written not necessarily
a literal interpretation based on 2019
that makes a very very little sense and
you end up just getting a kind of
partisan strategy around the
Constitution to argue one way when it
favors your side politically and argue a
different way when it doesn't favor your
side politically how does the First
Amendment apply to the Internet the
answer is it actually depends on whether
a president has put conservative or
liberal justices on the Supreme Court
doesn't really seem like that is a
particularly up-to-date document if
that's what it depends on how does the
Fourth Amendment apply to motor vehicles
the answer is it depends on whether
presidents have recently been able to
get conservative or liberal justices on
to the Supreme Court Thomas Jefferson
who believed that Americans should
revisit the Constitution every twenty
years probably was on to something
although twenty years is probably too
frequently maybe it was based on life
expectancy at the time I don't know but
the idea there is a good one and there's
an argument to be made which we often
hear from those who believe that the
Constitution is sort of more perfect
than it is who will say we don't need to
change the Constitution in any kind of
significant way because the Constitution
can be amended it doesn't have to be
replaced it's working as intended the
problem is that it's got to be easier to
pass amendments if that's going to be
your argument right the Constitution
does provide for amending it and it's
been amended a couple dozen times but in
order to get an amendment through it
needs to be proposed either by Congress
with a two-thirds majority vote in both
the House and the Senate or by a
constitutional convention called for by
2/3 of the state legislatures in modern
politics this is almost impossible and
you see it in the results the 27th
amendment was passed in 1992 but it
related to the compensation of the
members of US Congress
okay it's about their own pay if you go
before the 27th amendment to the 26 it
was in 1971 that's 48 years ago that is
a very long time for a system which
supposedly is ripe to be amended to make
it more relevant to modern day the last
48 years have seen completely drastic
change
culturally technologically in terms of
legal precedent on so many different
issues so if your argument is going to
be the
constitution's fine as long as we keep
up with amending it it's got to be
easier to amend it because it's almost
impossible in modern American politics
on anything other than how much do
senators and members of the House of
Representatives get paid let me know
what you think but I do believe that the
Constitution is an outdated document
already